welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
boss and marvel's moon knight released a
ton of new footage answering questions
and posing new ones like how exactly
does mark specter meet his egyptian moon
deity possessor and despite the
character names listed for each actor
who are they really playing and what the
hell does this mean the tone is like
fight club meets indiana jones it's a
bit dark at times cool by that i assume
she means tyler durden sneaking gross
nudes on the eyelids of indie students
there's a lot of cool new visual details
that we have to break down so i'm going
to go through this frame by frame to
point out everything that you might have
missed okay first there's our closest
look yet at oscar isaac's transformation
into the moon knight identity with those
mummy cloth strands wrapping around his
body and in addition to his crescent
moon shaped weapon being suspended in
his chest the wrappings cover two other
metal chest plate pieces showing how
this suit is really his body armor later
on we see him summon that same chest
weapon it looks like from the actual
crescent moon in the sky reminding me of
when doctor strange summoned the time
stone from a star in the sky in infinity
war their sorcery may be linked in a way
both pulling these handheld weapons out
of a kind of astral pocket reality also
i love how his eyes are already glowing
as this transformation begins showing
how it is coming from within him and not
an external spirit coming up from behind
or anything and notice how he's turning
away from a double-decker bus in this
shot which is worth noting because in
other trailer footage when he braces
against that bus his costume is that of
the dapper mr knight identity and in
that shot it's the daytime so there may
just be something about seeing his
reflection that triggers the
transformation which could be why moon
knight briefly flashes in his home
mirror why he suspiciously eyes his
reflection in the museum display why he
smashes a mirror in other footage and
when he's driving that cupcake truck
with a gun that might have been after he
looked at his reflection in the rear
view or side view mirror now this
footage confirms my theory that this
series will open with the awkward steven
grant identity and then flash back to
his original badass explorer mark
spector identity the way we're tackling
the story we learn about stephen and
then learn about mark what's wrong with
you mark why did you call me
and they're the same person but it shows
mark in an egyptian market chasing
someone by parkouring off a truck and
then shirtless with a bottle of booze
looking out at the pyramids
chronologically this is the way mark
spectre begins his journey there are
several shots in this trailer in
egyptian ruins though they seem to be
showing different time periods one
mark's first venture into the ruins the
experience that likely ends with his
curse that fractures his identities and
then two a return trip either to try to
cure himself or maybe to stop arthur
harrow from enacting some evil plot and
i like how like marks inner chaos this
footage is presented in a chaotic
disordered chronology so let's try to
reconstruct this forensically to
understand what's going on there is a
new wide shot showing a temple that's
filled with these massive statues as
well as some lit torches and stools
arranged on the upper section
overlooking the lower area almost like
thrones because seated in front of each
of these stools are statues this general
scene seems to match the shot that we've
seen of mark before in his rugged
archaeologist's attire your classic
indiana jones look but the bigger
statues looming in over these pedestals
from behind seem to be showing a
confluence of influences a winged figure
and then on the far right maybe a
hippopotamus and then i think to the
left of that head in the center a snake
and then some other statues with curved
appearances might be a head down there
with perhaps some curved horns it just
looks like each of these larger statues
correspond with the thrones below so in
total you got nine authorities
reflecting totally different backgrounds
and the wide shot shows some seated
people on each of those thrones three in
the front then one on the right side and
then another person in a red gown
walking up the steps on the left to
another throne we actually get a closer
look at this moment later in the
featurette where that red gown woman
passes mark as one of the seated dudes
on higher level walks rightward that
woman of the red gown is definitely not
dressed for exploring ancient ruins so
i'm guessing she could be a kind of
apparition a spirit inhabiting this
chamber seeking others to fill the seats
to help her complete a kind of ritual i
mean obviously there's still a lot we
don't know about this moon night series
but we do know that there are gonna be
some pretty sick outfits in the show
this guy or guys know how to dress and
our friends at epic hero shop are here
to help you be as stylish as the mini
looks of moon knight with the release of
some new moon knight inspired merch they
have two really cool hoodie designs a
black one with a konshu head logo and
the phrase embrace the chaos and a white
one more in the style of the mr knight
look moon knight is going to be what
everyone is going to be talking about
this spring and you will have the cool
apparel to go along with that
conversation keep an eye out for those
designs getting released today along
with the other moon night gear that epic
hero shop has in store really my
favorite part about epic hero shop is
that so many of their designs are clever
takes on the properties we love the most
a rogers the musical logo shirt in the
style of hamilton or mobius from loki
riding a jet ski they make shirts in
gear that just really capture the geeky
zeitgeist that you won't find anywhere
else so sign up for their newsletter at
the bottom of their website to get
notified about the moon knight merch
drops and check out all of their
incredible products like this stupid
shirt that i love it that you guys show
support by buying at epicheroshop.com
be your own hero now i gotta step back
from this and say marvel definitely has
a thing right now for confused heroes
walking into ornately carved rooms with
deep ties to ancient history looking up
at a row of mystery thrones some seeded
some not and like we are doing with the
illuminati and multiverse of madness
footage i just love the mystery a lineup
of empty seats presents it raises the
question of what other ancient occult
figures in the mcu might have occupied
these seats we have one throne room
showing how the mcu plans to expand
multiversally another throne room
showing how the mcu plans to expand
supernaturally so in this case other
seats could be occupied by c'thon the
elder god who wrote the darkhold hold
and originally cursed wanda max smoff
with her chaos magic someone we will
likely meet in multiverse madness based
on the new clues we've been uncovering
that horned head on the altar of the
darkhold temple matching the horned head
on the darkhold book so we've got kathan
and konchu and who knows maybe entities
like agamotto father of the mystic arts
of doctor strange or of course our lord
and savior mephisto all of them could be
part of this panel so i think what we
are seeing here is a kind of ancient
ritual that mark as an indiana jones
type fortune and glory seeker stumbled
upon along with his partner from that
past arthur harrow who might be that guy
on the higher level and that i think
will be the past incident that empowered
both of these men believing mark cursed
fractured stuck in a new steven grant
identity that has no knowledge of this
past yet still an affinity to be
adjacent to the ancient world by working
in that museum so i think it'll be there
where arthur rediscovers his old partner
but arthur was given different powers
and more control over them that allows
him to exploit others and become a cult
healer of sorts and i think the other
footage we see is steven slash mark
returning to those ancient ruins
following arthur new shots show layla
leading mark who's wearing the white
clothes similar to that of the mr knight
identity while they hike through the
desert and then scale in some ruins and
then in one shot down below in the
distance appears to be a caravan of
trucks which might be arthur's convoy
the expedition that he leads using that
floating artifact in his palm to point
the way i think this will all lead to
that shot of mark once again in his
white clothes walking into this chamber
with a statue of konchu and then a shot
of arthur with his longer david koresh
hair re-engaging in a ritual in that
same temple that emits purple lightning
from the pyramid that could be part of
the same sequence where konshu mr knight
and layla see a psychedelic purple light
display and notice how in this shot
kanchu and mr knight's arm movements
match perfectly suggesting that konchu
may actually just be a projection that
only mark can see invisible to layla but
a spirit linked with his movements now
this promo also includes ethan hawk
saying every aspect of this show has a
duality and we've shifted the paradigm
now while hawk has been credited as
arthur harrow and since harrow is really
a super obscure one-off nazi villain
from 1980s comics i would just be
surprised if that is his only identity
in the show and now he's teasing of a
duality in everything on the show could
point to him being a host of a different
demonic entity like the way kanchu is
possessed saint mark specter arthur
harrow could have his own spiritual
companion with huge connections to the
marvel supernatural world making him
someone like dracula or the host of
catholic or sure let's do it since i'm
essentially the bart simpson and you're
all the class here say the line bart
mephisto confirmed yeah
you can follow me on instagram and
twitter at ea boss follow new rockstars
subscribe to rockstars for more analysis
of everything you love thanks for
watching bye
[Music]
you